[Applaudissements]
qui
[Musique]
déjà que la date limite de consommation
de tous les aliments qu'on va utiliser
est dépassé depuis très longtemps donc
ne les mangent et pas voilà je vous lis
également dans le public voilà c'est
très simple on va jouer tous les 3 à ça
ce serait ouvre par exemple
voilà déjà un peu autiste va démarrer
doucement il ya des chocs de vinaigre
blanc holcim m l'objectif est d'en boire
le plus possible en 30 secondes
à genève on va donner des enchères les
on a une vie aussi après va donner des
enchères je vous dis chaque fois celui
qui aura à l'enchère la plus haute devra
faire le difficile défi réaliser on
mettra de l'argent de côté bien sûr pour
l'association rêves de gosse image de
nous tenir par les enfants josée très
poissonneuses et quelques milles marins
j'ai attaqué ce qui vole quand tu sors
idéaux ont fait un idiot qui sort le
collectif et d'en boire le plus possible
en 30 secondes moi je commentais
enchères jeudi voilà je peux boire un
shot de vinaigre blanc ouais mais tu
peux monter moi je dis si on peut
prendre les eaux après ou pas parce que
moi je dis [ __ ] tout seul ça me
[Rires]
et en plus c'est écouter couteau dans du
vinaigre
après on mange un oeuf et après on se
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le premier chien d'hoffmann au combat
bonjour boabab molière c'est quoi c'est
quoi la propension pour l'améliorer
c'est un tiers c'est un tiers 2/3 ouais
tu dis commun deux fois mickaël à 23,3 à
faire de la mayo les gars vous avez
comme moi qu'il fait c'est 100 euros par
saute donc dit 4 roddick à 4 ans qui a
indiqué qu'au pire et du soufre dit-il
vas-y fais-le end à es11 en a4 c'est
bien 4 c'est bien celle var étaient 10
mais c'est bon tu veux le faire à 10 n'a
pas pas encore 5 chacun des gars tu vas
être malade assez dégueulasse
bravo mr
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'ai pas confiance de vos stars mais
bien une émission c'est quoi qui
viennent les analystes y voient même
temps c'est bon vinaigre
mais on est des arts ce nouveau défi
nous allons voir on n'a plus du tout la
même boîte avec nous je veux dire on est
au bout du rouleau mais lyon va bien
vous faire rentrer 2 tu sais mais on va
attaquer la purée mais on va voir et en
30 secondes est rangé je pusse le pur et
en direct et sur des fins uniquement sa
bouche
oh la la chaque gramme hengy rapportera
10 euros à la championne excusez vous
qui êtes vous
merci
[Rires]
mal mal mal par les analystes du rythme
et du vinaigre
fais toi plaisir alors attention je vous
dis fardel alors moi je peux moi je dis
voilà dix grammes et jeudi - déjà
lorsqu'il dit il ya 10 euros par tonne g
10 grammes
donc ça fait 100 euros par fait disons
rien du tout datant de savoir où sont
les toilettes au premier aviation
derrière du combat comment 10 g j g 10
grammes
audi gras mois jeudi 20 grammes est avec
moi en même temps chez brabus fitness
hammam pas vous dire moi j'suis mai
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les ago when heureusement comme ça on
devrait donc toi tu dis monaco 10 120 g
allez c'est pas beaucoup non moi je te
laisse là j'ai rien trouvé g après le
bois c'est donc 30 g ça ferait battre en
gamme ça ferait 30 euros cette connerie
c'est pas beaucoup 38 euros tu vas mal
non mais comment est trop loin comment
tout s'est passé ton émission au non en
fait c'est quand ça va toucher le
jackpot à l'assister
la tuerait ferry mais on est d'accord en
plus dans la tête de ma mère la purée
mon frère de 18 ans de métier alors tu
ne donnes et surtour à larissa attention
pour ce nouveau défi maintenant vouloir
se dégager
[Rires]
là il va falloir se percer le plus neuf
possibles sur la tête
en seulement dix secondes chacun casse
et offrira 500 euros à l'association
jeudi un sur la tête mais je peux dire
non tu peux dire merci
on peut sans casser je sais pas si fermé
non mais toi tu quand il est comme ça la
tête dans les épaules des délais [ __ ]
vous y regardez un toit 1-1 quoi un bon
mois 1 1 bah oui enfin
alors deux non tu dis pas d'où tu me jeu
mais hadji 3 et tous si c'était une
piscine la tête dedans non mais tu vas
te faire mal parce qu'en fait c'est ça
ah oui
après l'autre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je vais faire leurs dents son chrono
c'est en 30 secondes je dois faire
disent attention le record je rappelle
c'est un néo zélandais qui la con et un
ca 8 en 30 secondes
nos relations sur trois deux un non mais
attendez on va toi larry
[Applaudissements]
comme en 2007 son commencement mosquée
on et il m'a dit mika
le film sort demain tiens toi bien
jusqu'à la fin pas lors de l'armageddon
attention des défis bien des défauts en
2007 il va se faire suicider
[Applaudissements]
duret
j'attends les jonathan malo public
attention à toi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est trop normal week end quand on
arrête on leur laisse aller s'il vous
plaît que la réplique à voir avec mika
renard est s'est amusé lui franchement
c'est ça veut dire que le filet de
vinaigre les séries alors attention on a
tout le public qui a des petits suisses
étaient très simples regardez pas
laisser le jeu vous allez tous lance
également ça j'adore ça
[Rires]
s'il vous plaît si vous nous rejoignez
on est en direct chamboule tout ça sort
mercredi
et c'est vrai que c'est très simple tout
le public va jeter son petit suisse à
mon top où ils vont jeter sur moi
oh non pardon
sa portée contre effacés je suis ce qui
m'a touché ces 100 euros tu as est bon
que tu venir à côté de moi je je crois
que non je suis pas très fan de ça il
est des matins je préfère les yaaku
attention maladroit 2 je suis à la fois
3 je suis sans les mains
[Applaudissements]
bravo
l'écrivain public combien pour
l'association tous les séries 6 me fait
j'aimerais avoir la sangle ovale